- I'm back with Anthony Anderson.
Give it up for him y'all.
(audience applauds)
And yes, there is a
reason why we look so cool
and we have our names
and schools hanging around
our necks on placards.
We're about to have a spelling showdown.
The annual Scripps Spelling
Bee is so gripping,
so tense, the finals are
televised each year on ESPN.
It's a real competition.
C-O-M-P-E-T-I-T-I-O-N.
You can't even spell it
and you're reading it
off the teleprompter.
- No, I was looking at you.
- Naw, you wasn't either.
You was C-O.
- I was looking at you.
I thought you was used to me
and you was supposed
to spell competition
- I was looking at you.
- and you start spelling Compton.
C-O-M-P-T-O-N.
That ain't how you spell competition.
(laughing)
♪ I'm a singer ♪
- So, unfortunately this year's final,
I was trying to be cool to
like stray from the thing.
and I went T-I-O-N,
(laughing)
unfortunately, this year's
finals had to be called
off due to the pandemic.
A tough blow
for my next guests who were
supposed to be competing.
Well today they'll get their chance.
Let's meet them.
First, she has competed
in spelling bees since
she was six years old.
Last year, she made it to the second round
of Scripps Nationals Bee.
Meet 14 year old Colette.
- C-O-L-E-T-T-E.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- You totally rock.
- C-O-L-E-T-T-E.
(laughing)
- He's competitive.
I like it, folks.
Next he's been competing in
bees since he was in diapers
and made it to the National
Spelling Bee three times.
Meet 11 year olds Akash.
What's up?
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Hi, thanks Kelly.
- A-K-A-S-H.
- It's on the screen.
- Thank you so much.
Alright, so Colette, I'll start with you.
When did you each realize
that you were great spellers?
- I realized that I had a talent
for spelling in kindergarten when my
teacher used to give me
weekly spelling tests
and I got pretty much
all of the words right.
I remember spelling
chrysanthemum correctly.
- What?
- In kindergarten.
- I, for a billion dollars
I'd probably not spell
that right, right now. (laughs)
- Not at all.
We'd both be broke.
- Oh my gosh.
- And I know she's smart.
You can tell she's smart
because she said kindergarten.
- I know, I love she did.
- We just said kindergarten.
- I know I'm worried about,
oh, she's going to be good, okay.
Akash, what about you?
When did you know?
- Well, that is a really great question.
My parents say that I first started
to gain interest when I was about
between one and two years old.
We always used to go to the library.
So there would always be this room
for all the children's toys.
And one of those was an alphabet
mat and I always went there
and then they discovered
about the spelling bee.
So they took me to my first
spelling bee when I was two
and a half years old.
And yes, like you said, Kelly,
I was still in diapers at that time.
I went through the written
round and made it to the orals.
So yes, they did actually
announce onstage,
"We got a diaper boy participating,"
which was quite funny.
(audience laughing)
And then, yes.
- Akash, this is only an hour long show.
(laughing)
- Right.
- We love you Akash.
Wait, here's the lesson I
have just learned, Akash.
I am taking my children
to the wrong library.
(laughing)
- Well his parents took
him to the hot only
'cause they knew he was
gonna talk too much.
- I was like, I love it.
- They took him to a place
where he couldn't talk.
Sh, learn these words.
(laughing)
- We love you.
Well, okay, the official Scripps
Spelling Bee was very sadly
for all those involved called
off this year, due to the pandemic.
It was a tough blow for
everyone who practiced so hard.
Well, we didn't want all that
hard work to go to waste.
So we thought we'd give Colette
and Akash a chance to compete.
And it's not just for
bragging rights people.
It's for cold, hard cash.
(audience cheering)
We reached out to Brainiac
Kids who are changing the game
for kids' brain nutrition
with yummy snacks
that help build kids'
brains into their teens.
And they're giving the winner $5,000.
(audience cheers)
This the first annual Kelly's Spellys.
(dramatic music)
(audience applauds)
♪ Kelly's spellys ♪
The catch is with Kelly's
Spellys we compete in teams.
So you have a weak person on your
team is what we're telling
the children right now.
(laughing)
So we've got me with Akash
versus Anthony and Colette.
- We got this, we got this.
- Yeah, that's great.
You guys are going D-O-W-N down, whatever.
We'll go (laughing) we'll go.
I did that one without the teleprompter.
- Okay.
- We'll go one at a time.
Akash and Colette will tackle
words they'd usually have
in the Scripps Bee.
Anthony and then I will
have to spell the names
of famous people, which let's be honest,
might be harder.
Here to host The Kelly's
Spellys please welcome
the official pronouncer of
the Scripps Spelling Bee
and the 1980 Scripps National
Spelling Bee champion
Dr. Jacques Bailly.
(audience applauds and cheers)
So Dr. Bailly, what's the first word
and who's it for?
- First word is for Akash.
And the word is bucatini.
- What's the word again?
- Bucatini it's a long
spaghetti-like pasta,
but it has a hole down the center.
- Bucatini all right.
It's from Italian, right?
- That's correct.
Latin to Italian to English.
- Bucatini B-U-C-C-A-T-I-N-I, bucatini.
(buzzer buzzes)
- (screams) That mean you got it wrong.
(screaming)
That mean you got it wrong.
- No, no!
- Well, at least I'm going
to learn a new word today.
(laughing)
- That's right, Akash.
All right, next word.
- Next word is for Colette.
The word is ramfeezled.
- Ramfeezled?
- Ramfeezled, it means exhausted.
- Colette ask him to put it in a sentence.
- Yes yes, that's just
what I was going to say.
Could you put it in a sentence please?
- After a long day of studying
all her spelling words
Colette was ramfeezled.
- Ramfeezled.
- R-R.
- (laughing) He doesn't
know how to spell it.
Don't listen to him.
- R-A-M-
- Feezle.
- F-E-A-S-E-L-E-D, ramfeezled.
(buzzer buzzing)
(screaming)
- That ain't what I said.
That ain't what I said, Colette.
(laughing)
Are you not listening?
Girl, I'm over here telling you (mutters).
- We are off to a solid
start and I love that
we're gonna be the ones
that maybe win this
because that wow.
Dr. Bailey, who gets the
next word or celebrity name.
- The next word is for Anthony
and the word is Matthew McConahey.
- Ah, could you repeat the word please?
(laughing)
- Matthew McConahey.
- Mm, could you use it
in a sentence please?
That's what I'm supposed
to say, right Colette?
Use it in a sentence?
- Yes.
- Okay, yeah, could you use
it in a sentence please?
- Matthew McConaughey will
be accompanying the band
on the bongos.
(laughing)
- Okay, okay.
- So child appropriate right now.
- The etymology of the word please?
Its origin?
- Oh my gosh.
- I think that came from his parents.
- Okay, okay.
(audience laughing)
Matthew McConaughey came
from his mama and his daddy.
Okay, Matthew capital
M, it's a proper noun,
A-T-T-H-E-W, Matthew.
(laughing)
- McConaughey.
- Oh, McConaughey oh, okay, McConaughey.
Capital, M lowercase C, capital C,
whisper in my ear whenever you got it.
- Wrong way.
- O, my God,
I'm about to spell cough
and that's not that's not
McConna, Mu con a he, okay.
I got to go back to my,
how I did it growing up.
Mu con a he.
M-C-C-O-N-H-E, McConaughey.
(buzzer buzzes)
- I knew you mess up.
(laughs)
- Isn't that you spelt
Matthew McConaughey?
- Nope.
Can we have a steal?
Next round I want steals.
All right, well next word.
- Next word is for Kelly.
Neither team has scored yet.
The word is Chloe Sevigny.
- What did you just say?
(audience laughs)
- Chloe Sevigny, the actress.
- How?
Okay.
- Right.
Chloe C-H-L-O-E.
- That's a purse.
And it's nice.
- Okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
And can you please repeat
the last name for me?
- Sevigny.
- Seventy.
- No, he talked.
Interference, flag on the play.
Wait, what is it again?
- Sevigny.
You know what Akash,
I just wanna take this
moment to say I'm sorry.
- Yeah.
- Because I-
- That's fine.
This is how the
spelling bee works.
- Sevigny.
Sev, sevigny.
- Seventy?
- S-E-
- B-E-N-T-Y, seventy.
- V, seviny, S-E-V
- No, that's seventy.
- How many times you gonna say S-E-V?
- Well as many times as it takes.
- You say seven seven sevigny.
- I'm gonna say E-I-G,
(buzzer buzzes)
There's a G?
Or no.
- No, hey the time ran out.
- J, I don't know, geez.
Okay, so none of us win 'cause we're,
well we're all losers today.
But in my world, I'm with Akash,
we learned some new words.
See, I still don't know
how to spell Sevigny
but no losers in my world, y'all.
So Akash, Colette, you're
both getting $5,000
from Brainiac Kids.
Congratulations.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Thanks for playing everybody.
Let's all read more.
All right.
Until next year.
To find out more about the
Scripps National Spelling Bee
program head to our Instagram story.